hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we are
catching up we're catching up because i
realize and i've known this you know
it's not like it just sprung up on me
but yeah it has been a hot minute since
i've gotten to sit and talk with y'all i
really just needed a second a break with
you know christmas and the holidays and
all that and a lot was happening as you
can see i moved yes i actually moved
about two weeks ago and so a lot of
craziness was happening and i really
wanted to you know wait to speak and
talk to y'all when i felt like my mind
and you know my
own being was right uh again and i feel
like we're pretty much kind of there so
yeah let's talk about what has happened
and just some updates for y'all so yeah
let's get to it so first things first i
have
moved i lived in downtown los angeles
from like as many of you know from like
late july
to
like just now about two three weeks ago
but decided to move a little bit outside
of downtown l.a only like 10-15 minutes
away
and
there's so much that came into
that decision first of all i always had
this like
stink with the apartment like like
a mental sting like this
not
liking it too much mostly because of how
my moving process went moving into the
apartment when i moved in
the apartment had not been
cleaned not professionally it looked
like the other person just you know did
their own cleaning so i'm not even like
blaming them but then the
management never went in and did their
own thorough cleaning hired anybody to
clean x y and z i know when i watch
videos like this limited person doesn't
put pictures i'm like brah so i'll put
pictures for y'all maybe not all like
the terrible terrible ones but like i'll
put some pictures for y'all like
right around here um and yeah i i
remember
i moved too well i completely by myself
i had these three huge luggage and
everything i had been hauling around all
day and moved and i had no furniture no
nothing and so i get there and i'm
starting to see that it's like not that
clean like at first glance it was fine
so i like got in put my luggage away
then went to get some lunch because i
was hungry i hadn't eaten all day um so
i got some lunch and everything then i
come back and i'm talking with one of my
friends um hi karen
talking to one of my friends we're just
like you know catching up and then while
we're talking i'm like sitting on like
the windowsill i don't know if you
remember those like big windows in my
apartment how like you could like sit on
it sitting there because i don't have
any furniture sitting there talking to
her and then all of a sudden i'm seeing
these like spots on the floor and i'm
like and i said like i'm telling her in
real time and it's like what like
why are there spots on the floor and
then this led me to do some more
investigating and i start looking around
all these different things i start
looking under like cabinets opening
fridges opening like the bathroom
looking all everywhere and i was pretty
horrified and i was just like
all i have is this air mattress
i'm basically sleeping on the floor and
it's not even clean
what i was really pissed i was pissed um
luckily after you know
going down to that management office
because i used to be a person who kind
of zipped my lip and kept it pushing but
no not anymore and so went straight down
to the management office and told them
the situation to show them the pictures
i took and was like are you kidding me
and so they got um
cleaners there
i think the next day i can't that whole
like week it's super hazy for me but
they got clearance there i believe
either later that day or early the next
day but then that kind of annoyed me
because the cleaners come and the
management office comes with them like
yeah tell them what you want to clean in
my mind i'm like
everything that like what like what do
you mean tomorrow so they were basically
told to clean the spots that were in the
pictures and i'm just like
what so yeah i was always just had this
kind of stink about the apartment
luckily after writing them you know
email about it was like yo thank you for
cleaning but this was not okay they gave
me that um rent for those like few days
back which comes down to like which
country's like yeah 250 dollars um so i
was like yeah for the days i spent in an
unclean apartment in an unclean
space i'm gonna need my rent back and
they did
but yeah since then i just never really
appreciated my time at the apartment not
never really appreciated but i just
always had this like thing in the back
of my head because i was like i am
paying too much to be experiencing this
i i'm if you remember i was paying
shoot what was i thinking it was 23 40.
we'll see something around there but
either way i was like i'm paying too
much to be experiencing something like
this and so
around like
thanksgiving-ish i started looking for a
place to move into a new place to live
and was planning to just sublease my
apartment um that way i could leave all
my furniture there not worry too much
and then hopefully get a place that's
furnished so that i just really have to
bring my clothes and like my bedding and
whatnot and i was able to find that so
now i live about 10 to 15 minutes away
um i live with roommates and so i spend
way less money i save like a thousand
dollars a month now also that was
another thing i hated living that
closely like to my means and i've never
paid that much for rent in my entire
life before and it just didn't feel
great for my soul and so yeah i moved in
with roommates um and live in this
beautiful beautiful like kind of like
townhouse that's like stairs and whatnot
um
yeah i'm very
happy now
um not saying again nothing i wasn't
happy before but i i can feel it when i
wake up like today i woke up and the
window was you know letting light in and
i could hear the birds chirping and i
just felt so
really really great um and at peace and
that's something i'm very happy to have
especially in this new year and what not
and so that is my personal uh update and
so moving on to things like work so yeah
let's see now moving on to the work side
of things i still really love my job i
will say that i'm very grateful to be
with the team that is so relaxed so
chill
um actually when i let me
let me step back for a second because
now that i think about it i have given
updates about my job on instagram and on
tick tock follow me on instagram and
tech talk by the way at the black female
engineer
but i'm realizing i don't think i've
spoken too too much about it
since my first like one month review one
month reflection where
first of all thank you so much for all
the kind messages i got either through
comments or through instagram dms i
really really appreciate it there
it was very clear that i was not
completely
good um i was not completely okay and i
really appreciate you all for checking
in on me and giving me your words of
kindness and wisdom and encouragement um
and sometimes some of you just a
listening ear like some of you you let
me call you and we just i i just rent it
and i really really appreciate that so
let me yeah take a couple steps back to
say
after that one month by like month two
and three oh i felt so so much better it
was a complete turnaround because now my
boss was back uh my manager was back and
i felt like i just had a lot clearer of
a direction of what to do in my
day-to-day what my goal should be for
the next like at least like six months
um things to focus on and that helped me
a lot i'm a person who i don't do well
with ambiguity which i know is kind of
depending on certain lines of work or
just certain situations can very much be
a weakness i completely understand that
um and in that case for me it was and it
didn't help me a lot in my new job and
starting all of this newness the
ambiguity i felt didn't help but now i
am doing really really great i have been
working on a project for the last like
yeah like five months working on
developing a web app for my team for
other teams to use kind of like a
managerial
task handler web app and it's been
amazing it's really
like i am one of the main contributors
it's really me and this one other woman
um
on my team we work together and we
really just
have been doing the damn thing and it
has been really great knowing that yeah
when i wake up i'm gonna do these tests
with the web app and and because it's
really from almost ground zero that i
started it
that i started because it was like
almost ground zero when i started that's
there we go um i have been allowed so
much flexibility in the development
process where most of the times to be
honest i create my own tickets and buy
tickets i mean tasks for the day and
whatnot i don't really wait for my
manager to say something or my peers or
to say something about hey do this do
this do this because i'm developing this
web app and so i'll be like oh let me
add this or oh there's this book let me
do this or oh this feature should be
added in and it's really amazing having
that kind of fluidity and flexibility
and autonomy over something uh so big in
my opinion and so it's been a really
great
time now that being said i have been
making just
plans for what i want my future to look
like if you know me um you know i am a
planner i
like to have
a mindset of where i'm trying to go
having goals and whatnot and i have seen
that for me one of the goals i want is
to figure out
other ways to sustain
myself so see my lifestyle sustain my
livelihood and figure out other ways to
do that i feel like other generations
like older generations it was always
just the nine to five like seven streams
of income what what um and so i'm
working to start building that thing
like youtube things like my business
about two months ago i established a
business for transitioning people into
tech specifically when they're in their
job hunt really providing that hands-on
assistance i don't like to call it
consulting because to me consulting is
like hey maybe you should do this or
maybe we should do this like this is
super super hands-on i'm like yo write
this article contact this person this
person this person and do x y and z so
that we can make sure you get from this
interview to this interview and so i'm
so so excited to start really putting my
all in that and also engaging with you
all in other social media platforms
again instagram and tech talk and
whatnot and so i am very very excited
for 2022 i feel like
it's funny because like i keep hearing
these jokes uh man no one's claiming
2022 well
i am i am claiming 2022. and it's i've
been feeling fantastic so far in my
january it's probably one of the best
januaries i've ever had to be completely
honest with y'all um knock on wood ah
knock on
mental wood um
and so yeah in terms of career both
job but also my mindset of the future
that is really where i'm at i have a
goal of and i'm going to say to you all
here so that i am held accountable and
i'm like shoot i can't fail now because
i said it i'm that kind of person and i
have a goal of within like max
max max four years but ideally two to
three years moving to like moving abroad
i'm thinking spain right now and i love
spain i've been to spain before and i
want to move abroad and
just experience life
outside of the u.s for at least a little
bit and so i'm working on doing things
right now to allow me to do that um and
be like as happy as i can be throughout
that process and throughout that time in
my life and so when it comes to career
that's where i'm at with things um
trying to think what other updates i
know some of y'all i caused a bit of a
scare not posting for the last like one
to two months um i completely understand
that i am back i am back you know that
uh nicki minaj quote was like yeah it
took some i took some time to rest but
now i'm back now like that's how i am
like i took some time to rest but now
i'm back now um so whether you like it
or not here i am but yeah i wanted to
just take a second to address just the
changes that have happened and kind of
like say hey y'all
it's me again let me know what content
you'd like to see in the new year and
how i can help
you in your new year goals so let me
know also is anyone else claiming 2022
like i am if you are let me know below
what are your goals or are your
resolutions and let's talk about it so
thank you so much for joining me i've
really missed this to be completely
honest i've missed this and i actually
posted a video um a few days ago and you
guys comments i'm just like oh my gosh i
missed this i really appreciate the kind
comments you all put under there like
welcoming me back i really appreciate it
and i'm so happy to be back so thank you
so much and i'll talk to you later bye
y'all